This halloween you can't escape the shock
the terror of werewolf by night tonight it
is every hunter for themselves good luck i'll
be rotting for you but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own i can't
wait to find out what breed of evil you are
you wanna see this darling please
don't do this gas is coming for you
werewolf by night
Welcome back everyone it's charlie marvel just
released their werewolf by night trailer it's
got a bunch of easter eggs there's even some loki
easter eggs you probably spotted in there like man
thing is in this trailer in addition to werewolf
by night so there's a whole bunch of stuff going
on here i'll explain how it fits into the mcu
what the timeline is and what's going on with
the whole grindhouse vibe that they went with
for the footage like they're making it look like
a grindhouse film like it's from the 1970s 1980s
mostly because that's when the character debuted
but for example we just got done watching the moon
knight episodes you may have noticed that they had
a bunch of easter eggs for moon knight's first
appearance which was in the werewolf by night
comics also explain why they saved werewolf by
night for this instead of introducing him during
the moon knight episodes but if you're brand new
to the channel i will be doing like a full easter
egg video breakdown when they actually do release
it october 7th so be sure to subscribe to get that
after the special he will cross over into the
movies too maybe during the blade movie because
it sounds like that might be where moon knight
shows up next all them will eventually show up
somewhere in avengers 5 kang dynasty or avengers
6 secret wars 2. so like they're all destined for
the movies all these new ones they're introducing
through disney plus series but if you couldn't
tell the reason why they're calling this a special
presentation and they have that special intro is
because it's made to be like the special retro
intros that you would have seen if you'd actually
seen this and they aired it back in the 1970s and
1980s that's also why it's black and white and you
notice a lot of the film effects that they baked
into it like it's shot on digital like all their
marvel movies and marvel disney plus series but
they added special effects to make it look like
it's an old timey retro film so like the film
burns at the end like a typical grindhouse film
they also might have some easter eggs in here for
like the classic universal monster movie films
like the original werewolf of london movie was the
very first time a werewolf was done in live action
movies you also see some frankenstein easter eggs
in here too where you see ulysses bloodstone look
kind of like a version of frankenstein with the
stitches on his head even though they're going
with a very retro vibe with this funny easter egg
in real life you think of young frankenstein like
a movie that was done in the 80s where they had a
color technology but young frankenstein was done
as a black and white movie so creatively that's
kind of what's going on with this but it's not
meant to be a comedy like young frankenstein
or anything like that like it is meant to be a
horror supernatural project in the mcu but you can
see part of the reason why they saved werewolf by
night for this instead of introducing him during
moon knight is because it's so much of a horror
supernatural vibe moon knight is obviously a very
dark character but the tone of that series just
did not feel like a horror supernatural project
this feels like marvel really trying to do an
actual horror movie but if you couldn't tell just
from their costumes this is meant to take place
relatively close to present day it's not meant
to take place in the 1970s as far as i know
the actual plot synopsis that marvel released
reads on a dark and somber night a secret cabal
of monster hunters emerge from the shadows
and gather at the foreboding bloodstone temple
this is the place you see in all the trailers
following the death of their leader ulysses
bloodstone this character here that looks
kind of like a version of frankenstein
in a strange and macabre memorial to their
leader's life the attendees are thrust into
a mysterious and deadly competition for a powerful
relic a hunt that will ultimately bring them face
to face with a dangerous monster now you could
take your pick as to what that's a reference to
but they mostly want you to be thinking about the
dangerous monster that is the werewolf by night
but like you also have man thing in the trailer
here obviously very dangerous character as well
the actual main villain of the series is going
to be a character called varaki this person here
it's not somebody from the comics they created
them new for the series so we'll see what's going
on with them when we get more trailers and when
i mention this takes place at bloodstone manor
laura donnelly here plays elsa bloodstone
like the latest in their family of hunters
she becomes the inheritor of the jewel that gives
their family their name gives them their abilities
it sounds like the crazy game of death that they
tease their playing during the trailer all these
hunters are playing for this special artifact
it is the bloodstone itself and elsa will wind
up winning it gail garcia-bernal is playing jack
russell aka the werewolf by night you see him a
couple times during the trailer transforming and
inside this cage also attacking these tva agents
just ripping them to shreds r.i.p tva agents
really curious to see what the connection to
loki is like who are they pruning are they trying
to prune the werewolf is something else going on
here that they're trying to prune it does raise
a lot of questions about the actual timeline
with loki season two i've already done a bunch of
loki season two first look videos we got a couple
scenes so far that i've already broken down so
i'll put links for those in the description below
just like elsa bloodstone's family carries
the bloodstone through each generation jack
russell was born a werewolf because of what his
grandfather did with dracula back in transylvania
so dracula is a marvel character like there's a
version of dracula you see him in all the moon
knight memes like talk about werewolf by night
moon knight connections dracula's also one of
the classic universal monster movie characters
his grandfather got into a fight with dracula
and was given the bite by one of the werewolves
that dracula was keeping captive and then just
passed it on through the generations to jack
russell the connection to moon knight is that
eventually this evil group called the committee
comes after werewolf by night and they hire moon
knight to go kill him eventually they become
friends obviously then moon knight turned good
but that was like the first time they introduced
the moon knight character later when they brought
him back they kind of retconned in an origin story
for muni that we saw during the moon knight series
it's one of those examples of marvel introducing
what they thought would be a one-off character but
then he blows up in popularity so they try to
retcon in a huge backstory for him that's how
we got werewolf by night before moon knight like
oh you like this moon knight character okay we'll
publish some more moon knight comics within marvel
comics history he's mostly been a good character
using his powers as a werewolf to fight other
evil supernatural characters or be on supernatural
teams he's even part of marvel's legion of
monsters which they might wind up working up
to in the mcu like they could potentially do that
but there are a couple other characters you would
need to do that but like we just got man things
so like they're clearly filling out the roster of
mcu monster based characters if you're not a long
time comic book reader man thing also one of the
big monsters inside marvel comics he's kind of
like their version of swamp thing but interesting
to note he actually debuted in the comics a little
while before dc's swamp thing so technically man
thing predates swamp thing even though swamp
thing became a much more popular character
the big difference with man thing though is that
he's a much more supernatural bend character like
he shows up in much more dr strange type magical
stories he also winds up becoming the guardian of
the nexus of all realities the place in the what
if series where the watcher's original base used
to be the trailer kind of plays it as if jack
russell werewolf by night is an uninvited guest
but during this contest that they're having
they're actually trying to find man thing and
capture him one of the big twists behind man
thing's powers and i think we see a version of
this happening in the trailer he's attracted to
anyone experiencing great emotion but if that
emotion is fear then they will burn at the touch
of the man thing and you see a couple people seem
like they catch on fire during the trailer
man thing's real name is dr ted salas he was
transformed into man thing after he injected
himself with his special super soldier serum
derivative talk about captain america easter eggs
more derivatives of the super soldier serum we've
been seeing a lot of those in the mcu recently
then after he ran afoul of aim advanced idea
mechanics their big villain group in the comics
that we've seen a little bit of in the mcu we
might see them again in future mcu projects he
winds up crashing his car into a mystical swamp
in the combination of the mystical swamp
in the super soldier serum transforms him
into man thing like werewolf he tries to use his
powers for good and it does seem like there's
some kind of misdirect happening in the trailer
like they're there to capture man thing but then
jack russell transforms into werewolf by night
during the ceremony and they go after him but
werewolf by night and man thing eventually worked
together to free themselves with the help of elsa
bloodstone i think part of the idea with these
brand new mcu monster based characters and elsa
bloodstone is that even though she comes from this
long line of monster hunters she'll see that their
good characters eventually take mercy on them
and they'll eventually work together in future
projects just address the time variance authority
the tva agents and everything that happened during
loki in loki season two because the tva agents
are here and everything seems normal this might
be happening sometime during the events of loki
season one or maybe just before it hopefully
marvel will clarify that when we get a little bit
closer about where exactly it takes place in the
timeline but it might jump around in the timeline
a little bit as they explain his origin story
because we saw a couple werewolf by night easter
eggs during moon knight we also might see some
moon knight easter eggs during the werewolf by
night special like all the glyphs in this room
here could be a connection to all the egyptian
mythology from the moon knight series i'm assuming
some of these pictures also tell the history of
the bloodstones family as monster hunters like
looking some of the pictures here it looks like
a depiction of ancient monsters within the line
of their family that they've gone after talk about
classic universal monster movies this one actually
looks like the creature from the black lagoon on
the far left here there's a whole bunch going on
during this trailer so if you did spot some cool
easter eggs or references that i didn't mention
in the video just write them below in the comments
i'm sure there's going to be a lot more questions
about this and we'll get more footage as we get
a little bit closer but we wanted to wait that
long before they actually released the special
i'm sure a bunch of casuals who are just stumbling
upon this will be like what is going on why is it
black and white i don't understand i'm sure before
it comes out marvel will have some sort of prompt
or something to prepare you for how different it's
going to look like this is why we made it look so
retro personally i think it's going to be pretty
cool and it's just meant to be a one-off so it's
like a pretty quick one-and-done deal then after
that marvel will probably reveal what their plans
are for him in his next big project but like i
said i think that marvel does have plans for a
larger more supernatural horror type of team up
marvel released a bunch more footage trailers
and announcements for a whole bunch of projects
i will do videos for all that stuff be sure
to enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss that my next big video will be my house
the dragon episode 4 video so i'll try to get
to the rest of the big marvel announcements in
trailers next week everyone click here for my
secret invasion trailer video and click here for
my mandalorian season 3 trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!